why is it sweet when I drink from this I
don't get it you call everything sweet
Felix it's water I feel like you had
something else in this and it was water
[__] up
TS is it okay
sure I
ran we could just Gaslight you that's
been the whole
episode is there a certain age you're
looking forward to for the for the child
yeah sorry I should sorry both yeah why
not both for both for both no it's all
downhill for me from here you are you
have S stream I I went to [__] Sweden
bro everyone who was like 60 looked they
were 40 and they looked amazing oh yeah
you guys went to Sweden did Sweden
review
let's I saw that Norway food wasn't as
good I said Norway food wasn't as good
me and both say yes it wasn't as good it
wasn't as good okay yeah what else was
good about Sweden uh there was a lot
that was so much green yeah
yes we don't have any this is trees
that's more noral I I I never I've never
breathed an air that felt that clean
before really yeah going to Stockholm I
was like I took a breath uh and stockh
isn't even that clean that's that's
exactly what every swed I talk
to it's cleaner than the rest of the
world what the [__] it only goes up from
there they like they're on the stank
side of stank side well I asked you I
was like you know where where should I
go eat cuz you funny enough you just
texted me as I was flying into Sweden
okay and I was like what do I do yeah
and you were like eat this uh pastry uh
pastry you recommended this oh K yeah
and I tried I I I didn't have it what
the [__] dude I told you I told you as
well did you yes I had said bullet and
meatball I was going right I [__] up I
saw it in the airport and I thought I
don't want to get an airport one which I
feel like I didn't want to get it not
like it yeah and then I instead what end
up happening is we had lunch and we had
a show so I didn't end up eating it but
we did go to that restaurant you
recommended and they were that
restaurant was Godlike I'm going to
remember those meatballs for the rest of
my life I I am I'm gen was in the meat I
am genuinely genuinely willing to go
back to to stock home just for that meal
it was that good yeah remember I told
you about the place I was like I don't
know cuz my sister recommended it for me
first she she sent a bunch of like cool
hipster plays I'm like I think they just
want like good food and she's like okay
this one but there's only old people
that go there that's how you know it's
good that's how you know it's good so
I'm like okay yeah I I I I told people
online I was like yeah man I went to
this restaurant and uh and they were
like what is it I'm like I don't know if
I want to say CU I don't know if it's
like a personal thing someone in the
comments figured out what it was based
off a very vague description no idea
guess it's not stockum is not that big I
I figured it out and I was like okay
well I mean fair enough everyone should
have get to enjoy it it was expensive
but it was really really good right
those [__] Swedish
meatballs oh I mean I can never recreate
them no no and neither should you that
was impressive that's too much power I
guess it's like you go anywhere where
you get the local dish it it's going to
be better when
had now I realize it's like you probably
only had Ikea meatballs yes so obviously
like actual meatballs will tast
everything's going to be but I've always
thought of Meatballs is like kind of a
whatever dish it's just meatballs right
how how much can you make it thees are
not actually good we just play along cuz
it's it's actually well the that's like
our church we can't say anything bad
about
it the last time I went to ik I was like
this tastes like ass they're like
rubbery they're so rubbery I've always
why does everyone gas this up so much I
thought this was it no no we just have
to go along it's part of the got you got
you got to take the double use when you
got them there's no way she's getting
all of them all right what else was good
about Sweden let's hear it well we were
there for like a day well I was hear
Weir was good that was good the vibe of
like the vi the vibe of s was like
really [__] hate sck live really yeah
they're so
Rude Dude I I remember when going back
in some [__] in swen we call him like
a rich person [__] uh people did not
were not like they weren't the
friendliest in St no they [__] they
have the scooters
everywhere that that was
awesome
no oh my God oh my
God Jesus
Christ [__] chill out bro God damn
bro it's just a scooter it ain't that
deep I'll fix it he reacted
like they got the scooters in Japan now
have you seen them holy [__] it's it's
this is come full circle I heard someone
died from the scooter think I hit by I
mean I mean it's not very safe we'll fix
his later okay fix I think you were the
one that fixed it originally last time
he came oned it yeah heed now he's going
to have to Repose it again godamn Paul
gone a r
figure wait do you uh do you hate do you
hate he do you do you hate E Scooters I
mean okay listen I I hate them but I do
admit I kind of like doing it sometimes
but I I think they shouldn't be in the
city why not wait let's not change topic
I want to hear about Sweden okay all
right all right I I like the vibe of
stockhome because it's like it has like
a quaint feel to it at least the p that
we were at okay so's cool yeah yeah so I
liked it again it's hard to disc listen
I didn't spend enough time there but I'm
going back for the meat okay good uh
Norway was was I I like lash if it makes
you feel better that's all I want to
hear Norway Let's Hear It come on um the
food we had was okay it was it was okay
you only eat food and breathe air what
else did you do yeah that's all we had
time you just described
living my life the coffee shop was way
better in Norway than it was
in they had like beats it was pretty
good there actually I like the beats the
most well next time we go to Sweden what
do you recommend is uh what do we got to
do what do we got to do oh you got to go
in the summer beautiful summer we have
this there's this um propaganda slander
movie called Midsummer oh horror fil I
showed it to you why is itanda and
slander well opposite I didn't know the
word sorry I'm englishand slanderous
thank you yeah we have this beautiful
tradition
Midsummer and they turn it into a horror
movie oh really wait what is the normal
Festival just fun what do you Norm do
get shitfaced and go out in the fields
with your friends ex the fields well
that's what mid summer was wait what do
you what do you just get shitfaced you
just get shitfaced yeah oh okay this
beautiful tradition what have they done
to it uh we danced around the fertility
pole and sing you actually little FRS
yeah wow I I want to experience that
yeah that's really do you actually dance
around a pole yes yeah fertility pole
yeah it's it's a how how accurate is the
movie then about
nothing cuz I I do remember the place in
swed and I watch it I'm like those are
not Swedish
bushes where was it did you find out
Stony or some [__] what are you
rainbolt oh my God yeah that sounds fun
I want to do that no wait but hold on in
Midsummer don't you eat the [__] cing
yeah yeah people usually do people
actually
like and it's the movie in the movie in
the movie The in the movie in the movie
real not real is is it the one with the
period blood in [__] cuming in the movie
they had like they opened the can and
the per we don't eat our period
BL this is what I'm saying hold on
people believe it hungry H hungry in
Jaan they give you the when you have
your first period people give yeah yeah
kind rice
weird red rice what when in Japan there
is a tradition where when girls come of
age and they have their first perod no
say no more I don't want to know I don't
want the family gives them red
rice can I how do I leave the
podcast I can't skip
forward um yeah so do you like it uh I I
never actually it it looks vile it's
smells like you you will want of V I
just want to try just to say yeah I'm
sure it's good I'm sure it's good but
I've heard fromy you like it I'm sure
I've heard from every like person who
was eating it on the internet who is
Swedish uh because I watched a I think
it was like some [__] Buzzfeed video
where they get a bunch of Swedish people
that eat soing and they're all just like
yeah this doesn't taste the same when
you're not shitfaced oh really you need
to be shited I got I go to Sweden right
what do I get what's the food what's the
meal what do I got to get other than the
obvious ones other than no no other than
just meatballs yeah other than is there
anything else oh yeah there's a lot of
lot nothing there's nothing tacos what
burritos or taco Friday yeah Taco Friday
what the [__] yeah why do they have that
in Norway well Taco Friday have taco
Fridays yeah I think it was a marketing
it was a marketing thing I think T
Tuesday does it right thing that they
were really proud about in in Sweden
during our show it was where you um have
like a coffee break or a break during
the day
they yeah they were really proud about
this they start it doesn't make sense
cuz it's like SC mean you just take a
break and have a
coffee yes we it's F yeah but then we
asked the crowd we were like what's
what's F and then they went
yeah f f mentioned that was what they
voted as like can Bo and some St that
was what they voted as a number one
thing that they do better than anyone
else oh yeah taking a break isn't that
good is it chill is it nice it's hype do
you stole F now no okay and I don't get
it to be honest wait really why coffee
break like yeah I I [__] with it yeah I
love coffee I love you do coffee breaks
right yeah yeah I'm [__] I
might yeah is it cool no guys I'm I'm
not I'm not a I'm not getting a coffee
break I'm doing a f I'm feing right now
[__] off so feing with the Bros yeah
also there was a we noticed the big
rivalry it seemed like Sweden was just
had a rivalry with everyone everyone had
a rivalry made in
Sweden especially Sweden and Denmar
Denmark yeah yeah there's a lot
of the yeah that I know yes's a lot to
hate about the I get it I get it
actually and the sweds are just like
firing in all directions they're like
putting they're putting out every
fire but I mean it was it was a lot of
fun it was definitely I definitely want
to go back like to properly experience
it cuz again I'm just going back I'm
going to that restaurant every day I
realized maybe there's not that much to
do I think about it why did you move out
cuz there wasn't that much to do uh I
said in is for everyone else to enjoy
Sweden I removed myself well what a
m i I should start saying that about
Wales what do I leave to really just
allow it to breathe just give us some
space I had to leave some fun for the
rest of yeah cuz I was wondering this
seems like a pretty nice place why would
you want to you I was actually thinking
like cuz I just met Mary and took off
like yeah literally and I was like
better not do this [__] to me I was like
22 I'm done I'm out I was like damn you
moved to the UK over this I was like
that a crazy A
crazy like Japan makes sense but then I
was like yeah UK H to Sweden I was like
oh that's an interesting choice I mean I
guess it just made you like Japan even
more when you go to the UK and you're
like wow nothing works the food's not
good and I come to Japan everything
works and the food's great but the
winter suck in Sweden like it's so dark
you go tool I remember going to school
and like you're at the bus station and
you can't even see your friends cuz it's
so dark you're like what the [__] you're
here there it's just so pitch black and
then you come home and it's pitch black
and it's like oh co skiing is fun yes we
have a lot of skiing you sound like you
don't like it that much we don't really
have
mountains that's nor got to go to Norway
yeah we have we have Salon it's like a
hill
get it's like a small Mountain damn no
way really did get everything they got
the
oil they got the mountains they got the
they got the Beautiful the Sweden at
least have the uh the the Aurora
boreales kind of stuff or is that all
Norway too they got that too we get it
up north where no one
is same in Norway though they on the
border of
Norway damn Norway really got it all huh
yeah now I can see what Norway was not
we really beefing with anyone no they
just yeah cuz whenever you see anything
on all like all the things they're like
oh yeah yeah it's Norway number one
Sweden number two everything always like
I have no
enemies well yeah I'd have no enemies if
I had all the [__]
money what the [__] why don't they have
all the money it's so unfair they got
all the money my Grandad said this on
his death bed he was like he was just
talking [__] and he yeah yeah and fix
they have no
defenses strike them
now take them take the land time to
claim I'm on Miss is really why I
started YouTube do your grandad really
Felix they have no
defenses come
closer they open they have so [__]
funny that's so [__] funny they have
nothing we have all the weapons they're
not expecting it what going to do yeah
true I'm just saying you probably
shouldn't joke about that but yeah also
yeah that's the kind of [__] I want to
say on my
deathbed just mad just mad talking [__]
about everyone just say the most
unhinged like not politically correct
[__] oh God oh my God you still think
Sweden Swedish Winters are worse than
British Winters cuz I [__] despise
British
winter are so wait British wins are so
good no British wins are the worst but
you're
saying having noticed you're saying this
without having experienced a Swedish wom
also also can't you lived in the
southernmost point of the UK you did you
did not live in the UK you lived in
basically France light all right I want
to hear it you didn't live I live right
in the [__] middle no no yes yes you
also lived in the South you don't know
[__] I know how [__] it was yeah that's
because you were in the south in the
north we got snow it was [__]
nice wet it wasn't it wasn't even
because you were cold it was wet two
down south to get the S once every 3
years for 5
minutes in the north it was great it was
cozy we had snow it was fun all right it
was [__] nice all right [__]
you [__] you too go back to Sweden okay
that's the tax that we pay for living in
the better country oh sorry live better
part of the country sorry listen listen
we like we like being poor in the north
all right we love it we love it it's a
choice it's we actually don't want M
I've been to and all they had was sheep
and Hills so what do you mean you said
Welles was nice why you turn it on me
now why you turn it on me now CU you
said [__]
you listen Sweden's cool Sweden's
cool you went to like the weird uh yeah
you mentioned this to me you went to
like the weird Italian it's portes
Portuguese oh yeah yeah that was cool uh
p p that was a really cool place I like
I like whales but I I do remember I
don't remember if I said I feel like I
said this last time but people were like
this is not my I posted all these photos
it was all sunny and everyone's like
this is not my
Wells we do we do get like 10 days a
year where it's Sun yeah I think I went
that week but I also like the gloominess
cuz it REM okay hold up let me let me
say something let them cook it's like
you probably really appreciate the
Swedish Summers because the winters are
so dark and gloomy that I really
appreciate when the sun doesn't get a
summer okay we do we do it's kind of
warm it's we we have a good one week
list yeah and then it's too warm no AC
and you're just [__] you're like this
sucks bring it
back comes
in well at least we have crisps those
are good good crisps there's crisps
everywhere yeah but they suck UK crisps
are by far the best do you have them in
Sweden no what the [__] you have the
Estella sour cream onion well that's
what we we have the DI you never dip dip
for crisps yes you get the sour cream
with the mix you know that that tells me
Chris can't stand on their no no they
can't stand on their they can't stand on
their own double flavor no [__] I'm out
of
it God damn